Greg Maddux set to join us the first
ever Diamond Resorts Tournament of
Champions is the LPGA season opener set
for this weekend
Greg down there participating among the
50 celebrities you got John Smoltz Roger
Clemens Larry Fitzgerald and of course
Greg Maddux who joins us on the program
Greg thanks for joining us good morning
what kind of picture would you be in
today's baseball game well you know
that's that's really hard to say you
know I think you grow up learning how to
pitch one way and as you get older and
you know pitching starts to change a
little bit you know I think you know I
was taught to throw strikes and and get
hitters out in the strike zone and and
now pitching is uh it's kind of turned
the other way where they try to get
hitters out out of the strike zone so I
think you know I don't know if I would
adapt it to that or not you know I'd
like to think I could but who knows what
would happen but you came up is a pretty
hard thrower I don't know what your
fastball topped out at but you know if
your throwing 95 or 96 and then you
something changed and you became a
different style of pitcher yeah I think
you know I threw hard well hard enough
when I was you know younger and you know
you learned that you know it's not so
much velocity its location and the
ability to change speeds and and I think
you know I had a better chance to win if
I if I pitched two locations to hitters
weaknesses as opposed to just we're back
and let it fly and you wanted to get the
hitter the hitter was going to get
himself out like you didn't I mean
that's how you won 18 Gold Gloves
because you expected them to put the
battle on the ball was that the strategy
well it just was the way it was it
wasn't necessarily the strategy you know
I didn't really have swing and miss
stuff you know so I had to rely on
really trying to keep the ball in front
of the outfielders you know I wasn't
really worried about giving up singles
and stuff but I I did what I could to
try to keep the ball in front of the
outfielders and you know not walk
anybody and and you know make him get
three singles to score
also I look at these starters and it
feels like if you go five you did a
great job I mean we have this quality
start standard are we babying pitchers
too much here well you know the quality
start you know I'd love to see it be
seven innings and three or less runs I
mean you know a four and a half er a is
uh you know it's about average maybe
slightly below average you know you
think you'd like to you know have to do
better in a four and a half runs a game
to be considered quality you know
toughest out of your career well there
was a lot of them Dan I mean there was a
you know there were one or two guys on
every team that hit me around pretty
good you know you know Luis Gonzalez
Mickey morandini Tony Gwynn I mean you
could pick a team and I'll give you two
guys that were tough to get out you know
for me personally and you know luckily
you beat lineups and not and not hitters
you know you've got to kind of sometimes
you got to pick your fights and know
where your 27 outs are how did you do
against bonds you know what I I didn't
do good against them the first half of
the career in the second half of the
career I did pretty well against him you
know I think he was easily the best
hitter in in baseball I mean he he he
was the guy when I was playing and you
know like I said you got to pick your
fights oh you know you think you got to
do what you can to get Jeff Kim out and
the rest of the guys I got you striking
up on 16 times in your career that's
that's the most of any pitcher versus
bonds congratulations Greg well you know
what thank you but you know I think it
took me over a hundred and to do that I
think if some guys would have faced them
as much as I did they probably would
have struck them out a lot more I
remembered you know having conversations
with Smoltz and Glavine and they talked
about Tony Gwynn and they just said it
didn't matter
sometimes what you through you could
tell him what you were throwing like you
just there it didn't matter
did you ever get that feeling like I
doesn't matter what I
you know what it it didn't matter it
mattered because you wanted to keep him
to a single so usually if you kept the
ball down on the way off of him you very
rarely would give up a double and you
know it goes back to the beaten lineups
again you know you had to get Ken
Caminiti out behind him if he did that
you were gonna be okay
how much baseball he was he was Tony was
easily the best pure hitter in baseball
you know he very rarely would he swing
and miss how much baseball are you
involved with now how much do you watch
well you know what I don't watch a whole
lot I watched a little bit i watch the
postseason for sure last year I enjoyed
that but right now I'm the volunteer
coach at UNLV this is going to be my
third year over there and you know my
son goes there I get a chance to coach
him and then about 17 other pitchers and
it's kind of a part-time gig we only
play 50 games we only practice five days
a week and it's not you know eight 10
hour days like it is in Pro Bowl so um
I'm enjoying that I get a chance to stay
in the game and at the same time try to
pass down what I learned
can you teach your style absolutely you
can teach it you know you know you teach
the style the style is the style
hopefully the guys doing it or throwing
95 and not 85 you know what I mean I
mean it's it's just a philosophy about
you know being able to locate your
fastball and change speeds you know and
the pitcher that does that the best is
going to win it's not always a speed
contest you know the hardest thrower
doesn't always win the best pitcher wins
and and I think that's going to continue
to be that way as long as we play
baseball but you know the guys do
nowadays you know the fast balls are
electric and and you know you're seeing
97-98 you're even seeing a hundred from
a couple guys and the velocity is
impressive man I sit back on my couch
and watch it and go holy cow these guys
are blowing you know and I got the nasty
sliders to go with it and it's tough
hitting right now he's Greg Maddux the
hole
Famer four-time siyoung winner 18 time
Gold Glove winner joining us but one of
the more impressive stats I found out
Greg is 14 stolen base attempts
successful 11 times yeah
thank you it was pretty fun you know I
think you know I think chipper got me
twice at third base it was a first and
second 3 2 count one out you know that's
kind of a sitting duck going into third
so but uh yeah I'd surprise and run in
the bases and you know if you get a
chance to still a base and they're not
holding your on or paying any attention
to you why not try to take it no I can't
lie to you you didn't look fast well you
don't have to be faster still a base
sometimes you know especially if you're
on the back end of a double steal you
don't have to be that fast at all oh
yeah well yeah unfortunately I was on
the front end of those ones did you ever
have a prank pulled on you since you
were one of the old time pranksters
anybody get you uh you know they got me
what learn look goofy clothes and shoes
on the planes and when I was a rookie
you know that was really about it you
know just a lot of verbal name-calling
and abuse like that and it's all in good
fun you know but uh you know we had fun
with one another and you know sometimes
what goes around comes around so you
know it's a long season and you do
things to stay loose and have fun and
you know Smoltz he was good at it and
Steve Avery was good at it those guys
back in the day and you know I used to
sit back and watch and enjoy give me the
one you can actually tell us on the air
that you did I didn't really do a whole
lot oh no no you know I wouldn't really
do a whole lot of stuff for guys you
know I might put certain items in their
locker that might have been fouling up
not just and and you know good good good
disgusting clubhouse humor stuff like
that but
you know it's just all in good fun David
Wells once described you as the silent
scumbag was that a compliment no boomer
boomer wasn't actually the cleanest guy
in the world either be honest with me
but he was fun to play with you know I
enjoyed my last couple years playing
with boomer it was nice to have kind of
a guy my age still in the game and you
know we had some good times we had some
good time sitting on the bench and and
also playing golf from time to time did
you ever feel like you had to sell the
game you know the Commissioner came out
and said Mike Trout needs to sell the
game you know you were one of the
marquee pitchers did you ever get any of
that pressure from Commissioner Selig
that you got to be out there selling the
game and selling yourself as a
personality
no I didn't I never did get that you
know I think I think I did my best to
try to respect the game and and and do
the right thing you know every day and
[Music]
you know personally you know you're
doing what you can for your team you
know there's you a lot of things
individually in baseball but the bottom
line is it's a team game and I always
tried to remember that and and at the
same time respect the game respect your
teammates respect your opponents I mean
they have just as much right to be on
the field as you and you know I just
tried to do it the right way how often
is chicks dig the long ball that
commercial you did how often does that
come up weekly it comes up it's amazing
how often that comes up you know I'm
down in Orlando playing in this time and
resorts tournament and it came up about
two times yesterday from people just
walking around with of course so uh I
mean it's jeez it's been over 20 years
since we did that and it's uh you know
it's pretty cool that people still
remember it Heather Locklear was in that
one right yeah she was yeah I remember
you describing a home run to me as
sounding like a car accident like it's a
car crash is that an apt description of
a home run
well I don't know I set back in the day
but there's definitely a certain sound
when it comes out the back you know you
don't need to worry about backing up
third but you told me you would rather
give up a bomb you could hit it 450 feet
just don't hit it 309 and have it
trickle over the wall well yeah it's
always a little bit easier to take you
know you're not you know it's you know
it's always easier you know when the
ones that will end up scraping the wall
you're thinking the outfielder might
actually catch it and if he does and I
need to be in a certain spot on the
field in case there's a play so you know
it makes life a little easier if it's
you know no doubter but do you remember
one of those home runs where you just
when you threw it and then you don't
even turn around did you have one of
those moments
ah yeah that quite a few I think I gave
up over 200 so I mean you know I gave up
a lot of home runs but Gary Sheffield
had a couple that were like McGwire hit
one Sammy Sosa hit a couple I mean Larry
Walker hit a few Galarraga I mean
there's all kinds of guys what's your
favorite piece of sports memorabilia you
have it on well probably my World Series
trophy okay you know I think we did get
one you know and yeah that was kind of
the ultimate prize in baseball and you
know the Gold Gloves inside Young's are
nice but that World Series trophy is
just a lot more special would you know
if one of your Gold Gloves was missing
like if I snuck in and took one like
would you know ah probably not I know my
dad is mom have taken one from time to
time and you know you can tip the pizza
guy with a Gold Glove you got eighteen
of them well yeah I mean you know I took
pride in myself and I think it's
important to be a baseball player and
not just a pitcher and you know knowing
how to
that's your ground balls one of them
well have fun at the golf tournament
good to catch up with you and thanks for
joining us Greg we appreciate your time
absolutely thanks Dan
all right we'll see it but for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]